oh man oh man she's fast enough
for you oh man
rob's got a good one
once i hear it i can like do it better
once i hear it
the millennium falcon
it's a fast ship all right
it's such a
funny
because you can keep watching because i
get richard
impression he does c3po it's so [ __ ]
good
oh we're live no we're not are we
actually live
the show started we're just sitting here
talking about [ __ ] star wars videos
that's beautiful speed of thing we're
live we're actually live this is amazing
we've been live we're just spending
falcon
we should start the show again because
we just watched snl
sketches for the past five minutes
this is great it's great stuff hey this
is a fast ship it's gonna be the
weirdest podcast ever when people listen
in because it's gonna be like so so it
has started apparently apparently we're
live this whole time okay i don't
realize
so do we
should we talk about video games or
should we just keep going with the snl
just keep talking should we start the
show we should do a hard start at least
for the podcast because then
because then because like i can just
edit that out easy to cut yeah yeah easy
oh do you want to do christopher walker
for the intro
okay you do it okay let's go for it
hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly hangout every tuesday 2 p.m
pacific right here on gamespot.com
and danny o'dwyer yeah yes i'm robert
hanlory
jake decker can you do a christopher
walken impression uh it's not as good as
your guys i like it who's all right
that's kind of like a bulgarian
christopher walken i think how you doing
everyone what's going on overwatch there
we said it that's the last time we're
going to mention every single video you
make today has to have at least one
video mention of overwatch so that's
ours done overwatch contractually
obliged blizzard you're happy let's talk
about video games let's do it let's talk
about a video game that isn't overwatch
let's talk about
the last expansion back for our game of
the year 2015. the witcher 3 wild hunt
uh blood and wine jake we had you on a
little while ago to talk about it it was
the last week of the week before two
weeks ago yeah i don't know yeah it was
after our preview event that rob and i
both played this game fell in like a
weird embargo time where we got you in
to talk about it early but couldn't
really talk about it um and it's out
today i guess yeah you can get it for on
psn
xbox whatever for 20 cool all right uh
so let's chew into it i guess you've
completed it i'm guessing you're going
through it a second time already yeah so
i finished it
last week and now i'm now that i have it
on playstation 4 i have my actual save
so i can kind of see what the
differences are with a save that i've
played through cool awesome uh rob you
played a bit of it as well yeah well we
had the preview version so i got like
the first what was it two hours we
played yeah i think it was about two
hours two three hours so i've gotten a
nice taste of it um but yeah all weekend
i've been kind of trying to play catch
up with hearts of stone right uh
well what was cool was that friday they
when we the build we saw had this this
update that was implemented implemented
last friday oh with all the ui stuff
yeah yeah yeah uh so i got to uh mess
around with that and that was really
helpful to like kind of come back in um
into the
to the uh game with um yeah talk about
that a little bit first actually what is
in that update what's it rob what's in
it it's like ui stuff like the map
apparently like zooms out way better and
stuff yeah the map is much more
responsive i think it's there's always
like a like a kind of like a second
delay with a lot of that ui but uh
regardless yeah the map is really cool
what i actually i think i love the most
is
so often you're like going back and
forth into the map but now you have like
up to what three different types of
waypoints you can set so you can set
like a boss it's like say you run across
like a really high level boss yeah
that's out in the open you can like mark
that specific spot with the red skull
and be like okay now i know what's there
i'll come back there like three levels
exactly uh and so there's different
types of that so i was having a blast
like setting different like waypoints
trying to like catch up on all these
quests uh but yeah the ui in general is
it's much it's probably the best update
i've seen to that um
as far as you guy goes yeah like they've
split up like your armor and weapons
nicely right so you can now basically
like differentiate uh an an armor repair
kit and a weapon replacement because
those are so similar and i mean that
whole ui was a bit of a like they they
eventually got there like with so much
of this game they eventually got there
and that's kind of cool like they made
good on sort of adding in like the extra
control stuff and all that and i guess
we're coming up on a year now almost
until it's out so great that we have a
second expansion pack rob was talking
about hearts of stone first question
actually with blood and wine do you sort
of need to have heart system completed
do you need to have the game completed
what do you think is like the perfect
time to come in to play blood and wine
so you don't need a complete hearts of
stone i recommend it just because if
you're playing off your sort of main
save it'll kind of level you up to that
point so you're ready for it but i mean
you don't really have to i think 34 is
about where you want to start on that
and then in terms of story-wise you can
pretty much jump in whenever although i
recommend
doing it later rather than earlier um
because of some of the end game stuff
it's probably better just to wait but
you don't necessarily need to have like
which or three like finished finished no
you do not need to have it finished i
forget the exact point where you can
kind of jump into it but i think it's
probably at the beginning of
i don't know i don't spoil too much but
like after the big fight after a big
fight big first big fights yeah the big
fight that's all that feels like the end
of the game but then
i actually say the same for hearts of
stone because there's a couple of little
spoilers that happen sort of in that
area as well around there um so let's
dive into it uh i guess the first really
boring question i'm gonna ask is how
long is this how big an expansion pack
is it sounded like they were trying to
make a sort of like a small little
addendum to the witcher and after
talking to some of the cd projekt red
folks a couple of months back it sounded
like this expansion pack had actually
gotten away from them and was quite big
uh does it feel big does it take a long
time to complete so if you're if you
just want to blaze through the story
it'll probably take you about 10 hours
like the story is not super long but the
area is massive there are a ton of new
quests there's a ton of new stuff to
collect like you could easily spend 40
to 50 hours i think kevin van orden
reviews review said he spent 40 hours
and i think i'm at about 30 maybe
um but i'm already starting my second
run through now so by the time i'm done
i could i don't know easily sink 50
hours into this awesome kevin gave it an
8 out of 10 on game spot rob you've only
played two hours but you're a massive
fan of witchers any questions you have
for jake about this like what are the
sort of things that you
want to know about yeah uh well i know a
lot of people were on the same boat of
will you be seeing a lot of familiar
characters from the main game
all right
yeah i'm not gonna say too much about
this
but there are some very good new
characters that they add and there are
some characters
who will return
but their role isn't as big as
i hoped
um but then part of it too is because
the save that i played like i said was
was part of the advanced copy like i
wasn't able to use my save and i think
if i was playing on my safe
um when i've tied up more of loose ends
it might be kind of different like i
might see different characters i'm
trying to be as vegas yeah you're doing
good i don't want to spoil this
but yeah there are definitely some
surprises um but you will be spending
most of your time with
uh anna henriette the duchess of tucson
who i think is an excellent character
um there's another character who i also
won't spoil but he's from the books i
know a lot of people when i said i
wasn't going to spoil it like every one
of the comments figured out who it was
right okay um but i mean it's pretty
easy to figure out if you have read the
books um how many of these people can
you have the sex with
one i think okay right all right um oh
well well
he
let's just say
he uh jake here like without mods
of sex
he was editing a gameplay clip
or something okay i will just say it was
it was a joy to watch it was
it was definitely the most ridiculous
sex scene they've had like really oh my
god yeah
i mean it wasn't like
like there's still no no no
feel free to you know describe it in
excruciating detail
you're a video game journalist jake so
it's basically zero gravity sex
so
all right
[ __ ] that all right yeah i mean
that's it that's all you get we did it
we did it anyway
video games did us
it happened may 31st beautiful yeah oh
it's here okay that that's the big sex
scene of the game there might be more i
haven't come across any other sex scenes
it doesn't come across any hey hey okay
okay so what else is in this update
that's actually it
there so so you what i'm really excited
is i think like the main drive for me is
there's this whole new skill tree for
mutagens oh yeah um that and when we saw
the preview build they hinted you know
you basically you basically can can
upgrade the your hard
sign to throw down like a freezing
uh aoe type of move um have you tried
out any other ones i know there's 12
right so i've tried out a few one of the
big things with that is that you need
greater mutagens if you don't know what
that is um
basically you just need to farm mutagens
in order to get these right and then you
need lots of skill points so
unfortunately with the with the pc build
that i was playing i didn't get to use a
lot but i did get to use some and the
ones i did get to use were really cool
they were slightly overpowered but i
think that's the point right this is
kind of like their final outing so it's
kind of like
you just kind of have fun like one in
particular that i really liked was every
time you counter someone who's their
health is like below 25 percent you get
an instant finisher and the finishers in
this case oh really cool so it's like oh
you counter it and girl like dodges and
cuts the guy's head off and all sorts of
gory things like that which is which is
a lot of fun does that sorry go ahead
just as like destroy up new finishers or
would you say that there are some ones
that you've seen but they're ones you've
seen before but the thing is is normally
it was kind of random when those would
happen like i think there was like a
certain percentage to dismember and in
this it happens no matter what so it
does this all this stuff we're talking
about does that pull back into the main
game like if you would unfinished quest
like i have a bunch of unfinished quests
in the main game would all that mutagen
stuff without pull back into the main
game as well or is it sort of isolated
so if you have
if you have blunt wine then yes
if you don't have blood and wine you'll
still get the new ui but you won't get
the new mutagen okay
um so yeah if you complete the quest you
needed to get those mutagens then you
can go back to
you can go back to skelega or whatever
and you'll still have all these sort of
op mutagens at your disposal sweet uh i
guess the last question on this is like
as somebody who is a big fan of this
series like you have completed the
witcher 3 how many times have you
completed wild hunt at this stage three
okay three times that's quite a lot it
took me like 200 hours once um you have
no life that's fine don't worry about it
as somebody who's a big fan of the
series did this feel like a good sort of
last farewell
are you satisfied with what it ended up
being because you know waited almost a
year for this expansion um yeah what did
you think of magic so yeah i was very
satisfied with it i kind of like what i
said before like i think i need to
replay it with my save because some of
the loose ends that i that may have not
been tied up in that save are definitely
tied up in my save so i kind of like to
see
how the ending differs with that um but
in terms of like geralt's story i think
it's a great finish the geralt's story
um and i think
just sort of
they take a lot of sort of liberties
with this with their final one they play
a lot of jokes um i mean because his at
the end of the wild hunts the geralt
story for you know whatever way it's
it's it's kind of wrapped up anyway
right yeah so is this sort of like a fun
little jaunt off to the side exactly and
it kind of doesn't take itself nearly as
seriously as the main game even though
it is still very dark but like saved by
the bell like something like summer
break
whatever it sort of does kind of feel
like that but i was showing rob one
place in particular that you get to
later in the game which looks like it's
taken straight out of like a fantasy a
beautiful fantasy book yeah cool it's
absolutely gorgeous um
yeah i mean it that's what's super cool
about this expansion i would say is how
much different it looks stylized wise
like it's a very bright like just having
played almost all weekend
god it's like overcast raining the whole
time you know it's like it's it's a very
gloomy area for the most part like no
man's land and all that sort of right
yeah um but this is
the exact flip of the tonepool like it
seems like a very cool reef like
refreshing area to explore that's
excellent looking forward to it 20 bucks
you said jake i think it's 25 25 25 you
have the season pass ah got it um and
you get it for free if you have the
season password and then it's 20 if you
don't have it but you might as well get
the season pass
the stone as well hearthstone was pretty
good yeah you know smaller but but
definitely worth playing all right there
you go 8 out of 10 on gamespot.com you
can check it out yourself folks uh let
us know if you're going to be interested
in picking up the witcher 3 and whether
or not you're happy with how that whole
series ended let us know in the comment
box below
all right gentlemen i'm sorry i'd love
to continue our christopher walken
improv session but it's quite all right
don't worry about it i think you did a
great job rob you're beautiful keep more
cowbell thank you see you later jake
uh
let's get some new people in here jimmy
thang i believe this has got we're gonna
we're gonna pop a
a lobby
uh
cherry
here not you mike
you're you're just you're a lobby
you're all you're a lobby [ __ ] you're
here all the time come on you can't just
get rid of you i can't wait until to be
alive it's it's gonna happen yeah i know
we're all right yeah you got a special
you get a special pay rise when it
happens jimmy thing how you doing my
friend good welcome welcome uh thanks
for having me no problem uh for people
who don't know what is your role here at
gamespot so i'm gamespot uh
you know somewhat new i guess tech
editor uh i've been here about a month
or so uh covering lots of hardware yeah
you've been covering hardware for a long
time right yeah i've been covering like
uh pc gaming and hardware for close to
10 years now right
a lot of stuff has changed and a lot of
stuff hasn't changed you're still
plugging graphics cards into
motherboards and seeing how good they
run yes awesome well there has been a
bunch of interesting graphics cards
coming out in the past week uh the 1070
and 1080 both of which you have reviewed
uh
the section the title i have for this
originally was should we all buy a 1070
because i can't
like in recent memory i can't think of a
you know a series of cards that have
come out that have really sort of jumped
ahead
like it reminds me of the sort of like
the 3dfx days almost when you're like oh
this is such like a massive jump in
terms of quality to cost that you sort
of like have to jump at it yeah um so
the 10 both the 1080 and 1070 uh they're
both uh nvidia pascal cards and usually
so this jump from the 1080 from like the
980 and the 1070 from the you know 970.
uh it represents
arguably
the hugest jump that i've seen in in
recent history in terms of performance
and i think it's because a combination
of different things but
normally you get a faster you know video
card because of architecture
improvements or uh like a different more
efficient nanometer design like a
smaller nanometer design
uh both of these cards uh have been able
to enjoy both right so it's both a
you know sort of a shrink in processor
design
and also a new a more efficient
architecture so where did this impetus
come from is this like because you know
me as a layman or somebody who buys
graphics cards but i don't really know
all that much better i'm thinking like
is this something to do with like 4k or
vr like where is the like push for this
amount of
you know improvement so who's this for
yeah um
so i would say the 1080 and 1070. so
1080 is about uh 12 to 23 percent faster
okay it's also like 36 percent more
expensive so the 1070 then the then the
10 than 1070. um so 1070 is actually a
better deal even though both cards are
actually really good deals yeah 1070 is
only like 380 bucks or something 380
bucks and it performs uh
as well if not better than the titan x
which is a thousand dollars
so that it actually outperforms it by
like up to nine percent from my tests
and then it's like 55 percent cheaper
wow so that's pretty crazy yeah um but
as to answer your question about you
know as to who it's for
i would say if you have a 1080p monitor
like
you know and you plan on sticking with
1080p this is these cards are probably
not for you right uh they make a lot
more sense when it comes to like 1440p
or uhd as people call it yeah uh the
1080 can also do uh 4k as well um
although you probably won't be able to
you know max out every single game you
know with playable frame rates it can do
most of them i'd say so what games did
you test it on because i the review
obviously so the 1070 i tested on a
bunch of things i you know ran it
through uh about half a dozen benchmarks
or so uh metro last light which is you
know multi graphics cards yeah uh you
know shadow of mordor and things like
that but i also played some more uh
recent games so i played uh like
overwatch i played you know the pc
version rise of the tomb raider uh dirt
3 the witcher 3.
um
and yeah like at 1080p like it's going
to be able to you know max out the above
60 except for tomb raider which is
problematic for some reason called that
hair technique maybe it's not the best
port i don't know but aside from rise of
the tomb raider uh it will be able to
max out you know every game way above
60. and your monitor most people's
monitor can only like you know they they
mostly have a refresh rate of 60 hertz
right so which means that you're wasting
basically money or frames uh you know
once it goes beyond that
and so if you have a 1440p monitor or
really high refresh rate 1080p monitor
that goes up to 120hz 165hz or whatever
then it makes sense so that sounds like
the catch to me now now i know why it's
cheap because the universe is going to
need me to buy a 4k monitor to get the
most out of this 5. or at least the
1440p one right yeah yeah it's crazy
stuff so let's to me like it seems like
you know i am very much the type of
person i think a lot of people are who
like they don't go for the top top top
end graphics card i go for like the high
end of the medium or like the low end of
the top and the 1070 seems like a great
deal at 380 bucks so why would i want
the 1080
i would say
um
i would say get a 1070 um but there was
a use case for 1080 like i said it is
you know 12 to 23 faster but it is for
uh the enthusiast that like wants the
best the best right now it is the best
uh single video card right now for vr
for 4k for anything right um but i mean
you can save a lot more money and get
similar levels of performance you know
by going with the 1070 but i think
nvidia knows that people are willing to
buy something like the 1080s yeah that's
why it exists uh how does it perform
then in terms of the titan x with like
stuff like virtual reality like is there
the 1080 is ridiculously good at vr
right uh it's single-handedly the best
vr video card the 1070 is the second
best video
so
it's like i think
i think compared to i'd have to look at
the charts but i think even maybe
the 1080 compared to the 980 which is
actually above uh the recommended specs
i think the recommended specs is like a
970.
so the 980 is even better than that and
then 1080 is like
65 faster than the 980 wow at nvr
according to like valve's vr benchmark
anyways and how much is the 1080 at the
moment the 1080 starts at 599. okay so
even then it's like so much cheaper than
getting it so even then it's like so
it's it's about 600 bucks but it's way
faster than than a thousand dollar video
card yeah so even that's like a stupid
deal and then the 1070 is like wait it's
even faster than the titan x as well and
it costs like 55 percent less like
that's insane yeah so titan x is
basically like an unbiable car so
basically don't i think if you bought a
titan x like a month ago you're probably
crying right now oh god i've actually
looked at amazon already and it looks
like the 1070s and the 1080s are are
already sort of dropping in right so i
asked in video about this uh in the
industry there's something called the
soft launch and that's when you know
a company like nvidia will announce a
new video card and
embargoes will lift and uh we'll be able
to review it uh but it'll be a paper
launch uh in that there aren't that many
cards to buy so i asked if
i asked nvidia if this was a paper
launch they said no we actually have
units uh it's just in the first week or
so a couple weeks you know it's going to
be sold out okay so you'll be able to
get them actually there after so i guess
the last question about this and this is
the worry of anyone buying a graphics
card you just spoke about the titan x
folk um if i'm gonna buy one of these
i'm guessing like is there another crazy
graphics card revolution like six months
out
where like do you think these are going
to be the sort of the mainstay of
graphics cards for the next while
if you ask me no uh the typical cadence
is if you look like the you know the 900
series for instance nvidia released the
980
and the 970 960 you know a lot of stuff
and it goes cheaper from there but they
also you know eventually announced the
titan x so we might see the titan series
i mean this is my conjecture i don't
know anything we might see a titan
version of the 10 series the you know
1080 series or whatever uh and then you
could see you know
normally in this type of environment
you'd probably see
uh a 1080 ti eventually right um and if
i were to guess i'd probably suspect and
this is again my my conjecture i'm
guessing maybe holidays maybe one of
those cards either the titan version or
the ti version it doesn't sound like
it's worth waiting around for though
necessarily like these are like the last
one of the lines in your review was
crazy was like when you compare it to
the titan x it's up to nine percent
faster and 55 percent cheaper like
that's right so uh
first of all these are not the end-all
be-all cards um in terms of performance
there's in in in the pc enthusiast space
there's always room for more uh
performance 4k
running metro last light at 4k with
everything everything maxed out there's
no single video card that can do that
today okay wow not even not even two
1080s i don't think can do that um not
at 60 frames per second anyways
um so there is room you know for growth
so
there is
you know there is
a use case scenario for getting a 1080
ti or the titan version of it can you
run the 1080 720 uh 1080 and 1070 and
sli
no okay yeah you might be able to do
1070 as like a physics card right but
nobody really does that yeah yeah so
damn i like my hearty i'm so sorry i
don't i don't know much about any of
this so i'm actually in the process of
building my own pc at home
on the east coast i'm just going to give
my credit card to jimmy and like
it's great when we have like an expert
on it you can just like play with a
bunch of questions and he just knows
absolutely everything so yeah i'll give
you i'll give you my like passwords to
amazon everything everyone needs i don't
want that though because everybody goes
to me can you fix my computer like no i
don't want to do like you're like your
aunties
busted yeah i'll pretend like i was
smart enough to figure it all out myself
and take credit
but i'm saying if something breaks and
then you go to me and it's like
i don't have time for this
awesome so
when are you you're upgrading your pc at
the moment i feel like i upgraded my pc
i upgraded mine like six months too late
last year like i have no i had completed
the witcher 3 on xbox one which it looks
so much better on pc it's like painful
um and i'm glad i have in there for
overwatch and stuff but uh yeah yeah
yeah it's it's it's crazy how you know
how good this sort of stuff has come in
the past year like pc games like i was a
pc gamer for like for 10 years and then
i slowly kept it into the console space
now man it's the dark side it's so good
it's so cost effective now and i waited
i don't even think it was or maybe i'm
just like not a 18 year old scrounging
money to buy sound cards anymore so yeah
it's crazy thanks thank you so much for
coming on no thanks for having me really
appreciate it all right next section
who's coming in on our who's we've got
jimmy's got to go
review more graphics cards and and and
all that
hardware stuff the next wave it's coming
um
oh alexa's coming in oh great alex is
coming in hooray
the prodigal daughter has returned it's
been a while it has
do you want to talk about where you've
been you leave me hanging i have a
concussion yeah i was knocked out for
about three weeks no no uh no you
weren't in a coma no i wasn't in a coma
oh no no i was conscious sometimes yeah
so it wasn't a coma um
three weeks no no video games no
computer no like no tv no nothing
complete sensory deprivation i'm so
sorry that sounds absolutely on behalf
of the universe that sounds absolutely
horrible i mean it was kind of funny how
it happened
i was at a gathering i was that was
actually at pax east and i'm very sorry
for everyone who was there who had to
watch this happen uh i was at a uh the
kind of funny hitman party
and it's kind of funny that uh a sign of
agent 47 fell off the wall and right
onto my head that's ridiculous
like hit you where like on the back of
that it slipped off the wall and just
boom like right here and you saw it mike
right it turned around it was
freakishly well timed maybe not
well-timed but i turned around and saw
it just come off the wall and i didn't
know it was alexa at first right i saw
someone get rocked and it really did
your number like that's bad oh yeah i
haven't been i've been out of the office
for a month yeah so you can you still
can't really look at screens this is the
first time i've seen you right at your
glasses without that i've been wearing
gutters on the on the screen you don't
want to worry it's like a nerd so you
couldn't like read email or like look at
your phone or anything because it just
like hurts right yeah no and it's still
i still have like some residual effects
like concussions there's i've learned a
lot about brains in the past couple
months
no um there's no like oh it's a mild
concussion oh it's a severe concussion
it's like you have brain damage you need
to sit down right so uh yeah this is
actually uh the first week in a long
time that i'm not getting debilitating
headaches like every hour that's awful
yeah my sister had a concussion but it
doesn't even sound anywhere bad as well
you had but even that was she just she
ran into a glass window and like totally
ruined her for like two weeks she
couldn't do anything i didn't realize
like how you think about concussions
like you know mma fighters getting
knocked out and they get back up again
or like how do they do it players yeah
yeah because i was like i couldn't like
i couldn't i got up to eat and then i
went back to sleep like i was sleeping
a vast majority of the time it was
really sad so presumably like you don't
have access i was just thinking about
this right you might as well be in a
desert island because you didn't have
access to like your phone or the
internet and like so presumably like you
were staying at home right so your mom
wasn't like giving you updates on what
was happening in the games industry no
she wasn't she uh she confiscated all my
electronics because she caught me trying
to text people and she was like
absolutely not so she took them she took
that took it all away and um i came back
i think on like the 12th or something
and that's when i heard about like the
uncharted review stuff and
like on overwatch and like everything
that happened in between the second day
of pax and may 12th is just gone so you
like you didn't know about battlefield
for instance uh i found out on may 12th
when i came back
turned on the internet for like the
first time you're like wow world war one
all right yeah no it's incredibly it's
incredibly weird and like still i'm
still having some problems with games
like i'm playing
i'm playing star ocean right now
for review and it's slow like it's not
there's a lot of explosions and stuff
and it doesn't really bother me as much
as say uncharted does because i still
can't play uncharted 4 because there's
so much motion
i get really like oh okay same thing
with overwatch i can play for like 20
minutes and then i have to go like i can
definitely see that i would overwatch
that's oh yeah crazy no tracer cannot
play character can't be no well we are
so so glad you are back me too i really
wish you the best recovery over the next
couple of yeah weeks and months it's a
really quiet time there's this thing
that happens in la in about two weeks
but like don't worry it's not that big a
deal that is the only thing sustaining
me right now is my e3 hype
you're a champion to come back
into what is the busiest season of the
year so thank you so much uh in fact
we're we're here all here to talk about
the electronic triple it's on in two
weeks time i mean what day is today
tuesday in two weeks from today we will
be knee-deep in press conferences yeah
we'll have well we'll have all the info
yeah nintendo's the last thing and then
that's it well they're just gonna talk
about zelda anyway so we'll
two weeks from this moment we will know
what zelda what that new zelda is that's
exciting what it looks like well we kind
of know what it looks like what they
meant for it to look like ish so let's
talk about some of the stuff before we
get into the sort of speculation area
let's talk about some of the stuff that
we know dead on is actually going to be
at e3 uh i guess yeah first of all
legends of zelda on the wii u let's get
the ball running alex are you excited
for this yes uh big zelda fan
replayed twilight princess when it came
out we played majora's mask um i don't
think i'm as big of a like die hard as
mike though
mike
i like zelda a lot yeah yeah i'm pretty
pumped for this uh especially i've like
watched that numa and uh miyamoto video
where they first showed it yeah a lot a
few times and i just the idea of it
after like playing a link between worlds
which is pretty
open world-ish i'm pretty excited to see
what they would do on you know
wii u nx whatever it happens to be on
yeah so that's the one thing i guess the
caveat in this is that we do know that
they're not going to be showing the nx
in any form yeah so we're only going to
see the wii u version of it i'm a u
owner like i feel like it was worth
picking up for some of the games around
there it's a great little catalog small
but dense quality wise you know catalog
of games are you disappointed that we
won't see it on the nx yeah
it felt like dead on for months that we
were going to see that console this year
yeah definitely especially with all the
talk that you know microsoft's having
about these the xbox one whether it's
the stream box or the smaller xbox one
whatever it happens to come about or uh
the ps 4.5 it's kind of a shame to see
nintendo not you know pulling out their
big guns at the same time because
you know they're usually like a year
ahead on hardware at least not that it's
better when they release it but they're
in terms of announcements seriously
you're ahead so it's kind of looking
forward to that um it also kind of i'm
hoping begs the question whether the new
zelda will be kind of like the twilight
princess thing like wii u and nx which i
hope it's not i'd rather them just well
it's going to come out on both yeah yeah
sorry i i hope that doesn't detract from
the game itself like it has to be on two
different platforms i would have ideally
liked it just to be on the nx obviously
we know it's not going to happen but i
don't know i'm kind of worried now i'll
be honest yeah yeah i guess yeah well
you know it depends
it begs the question whether it's yeah
is the nx like actually really close to
a you know normal console d-pad buttons
kind of thing or is it this sort of
strange new thing and maybe they don't
show the nx version because it is wildly
different i mean yeah that's kind of
what we're hoping for i'm just like so i
know i know a lot of people i know a lot
of individual indie developers and other
developers and i talk to them and
they're like oh yeah nintendo approached
me about developing for the nx and we
said okay what are the specs and
nintendo said we're not giving them to
you really so nintendo isn't even giving
specs to like some developers so strange
well how do you develop for something
that you don't know what it is yeah but
make a game for it yeah make a game in
the morning later i mean it's not like
they've ever had a problem with
third-party development on their
consoles right
uh let's move on um next one oh here's
one few alexa final fantasy 15 that's
what we're doing it's coming it's so
exciting
end of september it's coming end of
september uh i i will not be playing it
on launch day because i'll be at a
wedding so oh really yeah family member
uh no uh the anger renee oh wonderful
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah better
um how dare they do that they work in
the games industry they should know
better i love them i do i'll do it for
her john um yeah no 10 years like this
is the reason that i'm that game is the
reason i'm sitting here because i
watched the launch trailer for versus
13. right in 2006 on a on a old ass mac
apple computer in my high school i
passed someone in the hallway and they
were like oh new final fantasy got
announced i was like what so i ran to
the computer lab and i watched it and i
was like i want to write about this
stuff and now here i am and he's coming
out 10 years later and i'm a grown woman
who pays bills and can now spend a lot
of money on collector's editions right
these games nice work um what do you
hope we see because we've already seen i
feel like a decent email we've played it
in fact yeah um i mean combat i think we
have a handle on i think we have a
handle on sort of oh like it's a it's a
war between countries um i want to see
more of like the cooking and and magic
like we've seen some magic spells but
not how you like level up magic and
stuff right i want to know more about
the characters they announced all of
these characters here's her character
and here's her name and
we're not going to talk about her and i
kind of want to know more about these
characters because that's what defines
that series so
that's what defines final fantasy people
find a character and they're like oh
like this is the person i identify with
or they're very they're very special or
they have some sort of hero's journey
thing going on and i feel like uh we
don't know enough about uh anyone
outside of the four main dudes yeah and
i would love to like i want to know more
about luna and quintiana who has shown
once never shown again that really sexy
badass dragoon lady
you want the nitty gritty i want the
nitty-gritty give me everything right
now uh a gamer i'm really looking
forward to which is being developed
actually relatively close up in tiburon
by 2k is mafia 3. um made this is the
sort of
very sort of interesting take on mafia
and i love what they're doing with this
like i really like the mafia series it's
always been the sort of interesting i
mean the first one i think is absolutely
like pc classic i adored it um
interesting take on the sort of open
world game in a way that sort of i guess
games like la noire kind of later
managed to dip your toe in uh but this
one said in new bordeaux african-america
american protagonist dealing with sort
of very interesting uh sort of racial
issues around i mean the whole idea of
like taking this away from the mafia and
calling it a mafia game in and of itself
shows you how bold they're being with
this uh either you guys excited for
mafia three yeah i played it for three
hours a couple of months ago oh what was
the preview on gamespot.com yeah um no
i'm really excited for it like open
world games are a little daunting to me
but
i uh really like the way that that world
is uh fleshed out and the way it feels
it feels really lived in and that's
what's got me very interested for this
one more of yourself mike yeah i really
like period piece games you've watched
l.a noir and then but for a while it's
just been assassin's creed essentially i
mean you have you have like one other
like the saboteur which
was overlooked a lot which i like but
irishman in paris yeah yeah so i'm
really looking forward to mafia threes
new orleans setting a because that's
pretty unexplored in games i mean there
are games set there but i'm really
looking forward to how they actually
flesh out historically this setting
because that's always appealing to me
like actually kind of living in that
environment yeah always we're running
out of cities in north america to go
into as well yeah so let's go to
syracuse or something
yeah syracuse syracuse
square miles of it
uh speaking of places outside of north
america mass effect andromeda coming out
2017. uh we've seen hardly any of this
game we saw like a weird developer diary
where they showed off like they they
tease as little as you could possibly
tease i feel with this game are we just
going to see gameplay e3 is it time i
mean they have to if that thing is
coming out that thing is coming out in
spring of next year like this is the
time to show it it's either here or
gamescom and i feel like they would be
depending on based on what ea has now
what we know they have and what they're
showing like they would be foolish to
not roll that out at e3 yeah i think i
mean i love gamescom but you don't
announce something this big or show off
something this big necessarily a
gamescom this is basically they're sort
of ace in the hall i mean yeah you're
working actually now working on a lot of
very interesting action games um but
yeah it's sort of a bad time to show
this one off right mike yeah it's kind
of also
worrying when a lot of key talent left
right
three months ago or so so that kind of
had me worried delays i don't i don't
look at it as necessarily bad
but yeah i'm curious to see where it
goes they did the teaser trailer just
showed wasn't like the main character
looking at a galactic map
the ghost riders uh trailer really yeah
there goes the johnny cashlong ghost
writers and those playing and it was
like i've and i've since seen like
via someone's linkedin or something that
there was some footage of like the
technical aspects of the game which
showed some interesting sort of player
movement uh yeah so probably a better
time and let's rattle through somebody's
a little bit quicker uh titanfall 2
coming at q4 of this year
toot and fall we're all having a bit
more titanfall right yeah do we want the
campaign and this one's a bit more
fleshed out we have we can't play
multiplayer yeah yeah i don't like
playing with other people so give me a
campaign fair enough and also vin
sampela pretty good at making
single-player games himself and jason
west obviously with the call of duty
franchise yeah okay we're all in
agreement next up deus ex mankind
divided also coming out relatively quick
at the end of august august 23rd um i'm
a massive dsx fan the first two games
especially the first game absolutely
classic didn't really get into the the
the new one but i noticed a lot of fans
out there uh either of you guys yeah i
like team and revolution a lot um had
definitely had flaws in how you can
actually choose your path through it and
how you get screwed over in the end but
yeah i'm pretty pun for mankind divided
yeah like all these games have mentioned
today uh this one also confirmed to show
at e3 um what do they need to do with
this because it's been a little while
it's been like four years maybe since
i'm trying to think when human
revolution came five yeah it came out in
2011
google august 2011 yeah so it'll almost
be
four five years to the day almost uh
second god i didn't realize it was that
far away and what did it even have to do
with this do they just need to do the
same again or like
i don't think they need to go towards
any sort of like making the levels
particularly big or anything like they
just have to iterate i mean they thought
what they did they did really well so
long as their iteration is like smart
and fun like i haven't played it yet i
don't know if you've gotten a chance to
play it at all no but i'm really hoping
that's actually a similar case with uh
dishonored two because dishonored one
and uh human revolution both to me had
the same problem of they kind of purport
to let you go through the game however
you want whether it's stealth or combat
but both of those games
kind of lead you toward combat as you
keep playing and i'm hoping both those
games you know not to jump into bethesda
quickly but i hope both those games
correct that so you can actually
actually go through the game how you
want because i like stealth and i don't
want to feel like i have to be upping my
armor and my damage and my explosives
the whole time yeah i mean that was a
massive problem with dishonors uh if
yeah it was sort of tried to be thief
and then ended up being you know more of
an action game and the same problem with
deus ex the first one was especially the
boss fights you can't stealth the boss
fights and sort of ran into a problem
here uh but since you mentioned it
dishonored two uh also coming out this
year november 11th 2016 excited about
winning alexa yes that game looks
beautiful also i think the narrative
narrative designer is cara else
yeah and she's an awesome writer so i'm
actually really excited to see where
that goes because of her involvement
yeah should be good stuff yeah i'm
hoping i'm curious about the interplay
between emily and corvo and how playing
through the game differently as them
right actually affect it because you
know dishonored one you can go like we
said pretty different paths for better
or worse but this one i'm like
like four paths if you play both of them
differently each time i mean both their
abilities are pretty distinct but i'm
looking forward to
trying that out for sure yeah the last
two big guns i have on this are call of
duty infinite warfare coming out
november 4th 2016. i'm guessing we're
going to see gameplay of this alexa
probably uh excited about that one at
all mike oh yeah sorry you were in
concussion land and all this stuff
um that uh the game director in that is
the former is the game director who did
reader and rise of the tomb raider oh
right okay yeah interesting so i follow
people yeah interested in it for that
but so somebody who's
good at rebuilding
franchises which have become tired over
time yeah interesting you excited about
this mike i'm curious and hopeful for
that yeah i'm flat out excited for
battlefield one that's the other one
that's coming out october 21st so it's
going to be a good
two weeks before infinite warfare drops
uh yeah alexa what did you think when
you first saw this because we did all
the reaction pieces and the whole place
was talking about it for a week so you
didn't get to enjoy any of that what did
you think when you saw battlefield going
back to well not going back going for
the first time to the trenches of world
war one well my so i my young my little
brother who's ten years younger than me
uh abandoned the battlefield series but
it started getting a little too
futuristic and he loves uh period pieces
and he's like and he said to me like a
year ago and he was like i'll play that
game if it goes back to world war one
right so like the first thing that
happened when i saw that was like all
right jake
i think it's really cool i think that's
a really awesome i think the naming
convention is very bold yeah yeah um i
think it looks really cool uh mike is a
scholar of world war one we learned
no one in the office knew this
apparently he studied in university yeah
i went to school
i was surprised i went to school as well
but i learned about making websites not
bloody world war ones i studied
journalism this was like a passion in
the minor i don't romanticize the war
because it's a terrible war it's like
when humankind realized we should chill
the [ __ ] yeah stop doing we need to stop
doing this yeah uh i'm actually i'm
really excited for the multiplayer rob
and i have like plans he's i'm gonna be
his gunner he's gonna be flying the
biplane and that's because i got to see
the gameplay they showed us at the event
oh yeah yeah so i like they're showing
like the plane diving like
180 degrees to the ground and then sorry
90 degrees i didn't study math
and then the gunner just firing up in
the air 90 yeah um he's flying 180
degrees to the ground yeah no uh but i
am i'm really excited for the story too
because they they mentioned the harlem
hell fighters which would be such a
badass thing to show and they said
there'd be different people from uh
different parts of the war like the
bedouin horse woman as well yeah and
also like i'm sure that like the
christmas truce and maybe the marn will
be shown
oh yeah do you do what do you think
there's gonna be like a football mini
game no no no no no alex new house uh
messaged me because he's you know like
him being into history and stuff he's
like dude what if they like shut down
the servers on christmas so you can oh
my god
oh my god it would be so clever and also
everyone would hate them oh yeah like
the one day everybody's home and can
play games but or they just mod the
server so that everyone's playing
football instead that'd be like boots up
fifa they could do that it's easy please
do that it's ea they can do like they
skin they just they skin two fifa teams
in like
like huns and yeah for pointed helmets
and then just like put your water cooled
down that's such a good idea there you
go
that's a free bea
and that's all the games that are
confirmed for uh well the big games that
are confirmed for e3 legend of zelda
mafia 3 mass effect titanfall 2 deus ex
mankind divided dishonored 2 call of
duty infinite warfare battlefield uno
and final fantasy 15. so let us know in
the comments which one you're most
excited about next i want to talk about
the ones that are likely
to be coming uh at e3 and the ones that
we sort of the rumors and speculation
we hope as well so alexa mike are you
ready to speculate
on the electronic triple yes let's get
our speculation so here's some here's
some really obvious softballs likely
games slash maybe that haven't been
confirmed but chances are that's we you
enjoy final fantasy we just talked about
it final fantasy 7 remake guess who
we're going to see it maybe
i don't know given the track record with
showing that game and just squares crack
crack record track record and showing
those games in general
it's not even start about the crack
record
i don't know you know i don't know
i don't think we'll get it i don't think
we'll get a release date
uh maybe they'll show some footage but i
still think that game is a very long way
off right um another one then we're
probably going to see i believe i mean
microsoft are going to be coming at this
pretty hard they are one of the few
companies still involved in e3 proper uh
gears of war 4. they've shown it off
already they showed that last e3 was
when they showed the darkest gameplay of
all time dark trailer yeah i was like
why i can't see anything like it's
you're shooting bats like show us
something else um you found a series
mike do you think they're gonna show off
i've played them all um i mean it's
coming out later this year yeah so they
should probably get on it i'll play it
uh they keep saying like the main draw
with this one is they're saying they're
returning to like the horror roots of
the first game which the first game
wasn't really as like a survival horror
no
that's a weird sentence
of gears yeah you know because that's
also like uh
rod ferguson was saying that
doing ultimate edition of the first game
was kind of them
backtracking a little bit to those roots
i mean like the scene with the berserker
for the first game and that was
i guess four elements yeah so i'm but
they say they're going all out with this
one and fighting the games is dark on
that track smallest train in the world
that was horrifying yeah and waves the
krill the krill would tear you apart
when you're in the dark um i don't know
i'm i'm curious about that one too i
can't say i'm excited yet that could go
either way yeah i feel like the beta
didn't really light anyone's like
expectations on fire or anything no the
beta was a lot of fun it was fun but it
was also like
like what is it like why why am i coming
back i was like i remember playing this
in 2006 yeah so it's also tough because
the the first game kind of
raised redefined with a third person
shooter totally so now how do you
replicate that yeah how do you do that
again
um another game actually of a very
interesting game that i'm very excited
about uh guerrilla games have been
working on so many franchises over the
years and i feel like for the longest
time they worked on franchises that like
certain people were excited about but
never got like the sort of mass hysteria
that people yeah exactly killzone was a
game that like sony was pushing a lot
yeah and like you know killzone three
looked wonderful and kills the two look
wonderful
maybe not as good as it did when they
first showed it off
but with horizon zeroed on there seems
to be like a genuine sort of excitement
bubbling about this game not just
because of how it looks but the
interesting way and how it plays alex
are you excited for horizon very excited
it's different it looks different like
every e3 people parade out the trailers
and we think oh it's another gears or
it's another thing it's a whatever but i
feel like this trailer when they showed
it last year was the the first genuine
moment of that besides the fallout
announcement was when we were actually
looking at something like oh this is
new this is something different so yeah
i'm totally excited about it it's going
to be interesting is this the
latest game was the last game you made
shadowfall i think so i think and i
think shadowfall might have been the
best kill zone like i really enjoyed
shadowfall i thought it was nah what do
you think mike i prefer three okay
decent game i mean i feel like they
figured that series out as they went
along sure i guess i wasn't a massive
fan of the first game um yeah so that's
horizon zero dawn uh coming i guess
we'll we'll find out soon enough look at
that look how pretty that world looks i
hope it's soon yeah um lawbreakers i
mean
playing that overwatch video game a lot
of people are uh i feel like maybe
gearbox's one didn't take off quite as
much we'll know about that pretty pretty
oh battle board yeah battleborn it's uh
it was not gonna steal i forgot it
except spy and looking at the sales it
doesn't look like it's doing super odd
who knows consoles i guess we'll find it
soon enough um best of luck to them but
this this whole area of like you know i
don't know it's well obviously that's
more in the mmo space overwatch is very
much his class shooter lawbreaker seems
like it's kind of a mix between a class
shooter and an arena shooter which is
something you know cliff blazinski is
used to obviously being
part of the creative leads involved in
the unreal tournament franchise are you
guys excited all about law breakers i
want to break the law
break the ground law gravity shoot some
people
mike yeah yeah um
so i wasn't until i read a preview scott
butterworth what did one did a preview
said he was pleasantly surprised then it
packs east i got to play it it's it's
really fun it's uh they the thing they
keep saying is like it's all about the
verbs
which
most games are but they say like you
know it's very much this kinetic kind of
mobility right it feels more like doom
to me then okay but with with
interesting you know like classes not
because do multiplayer i'm not a huge
fan of yeah despite how much i love doom
but it feels more like that it's just
this it's kind of a floaty really not
twitch based like it's not a crazy fast
time to kill it feels as like i think
we're in like the middle of the shooter
renaissance this year with so many good
yeah it's crazy it's like a bunch of
renaissance yeah nobody expected dune to
be as good as it was
that is like the craziest
like ex like
most shocking thing ever yeah
like that's happened in years in first
person shooters made was that how good
do was and overwatch is a classic yeah
like overwatch is is
a team fortress too and i would say if
you're enjoying overwatch and doom like
myself i was switching between them all
weekend i think law breakers you'll be
super into or if i mean if you're like
an old-school quake fan you'll like this
right yeah yeah i'm really looking
forward to this i mean the audio
tournament alpha is really good but it
definitely seems like it's looking
backwards i like the idea of somebody
taking that and looking forward to it so
i guess we'll find it hopefully we'll
find out during e3 we don't know if this
stuff's going to be shown uh recore
that's uh i mean kejri and funi are
working on this one as well my number
nine is finally coming out right right
there's right between that and then like
the red ash kickstarter debacle and like
everything else like i don't i don't
think it's it's a kg in a funny game so
much as it is like keiji inafune is over
like overseeing it or just like
producing it or attached to it in some
way
i wish i wish all the best for this game
much better than
mine number nine yeah
we'll have to say i mean yeah that was a
game you know that we saw a bunch of
trailers for and
uh no no i mean my number nine was back
in the day and then there was a sort of
expectation and never really met it
whereas record we've seen trailers and
we haven't seen gameplay and who knows
like maybe it maybe it doesn't end up
coming out as as big as as big as we
want obviously bigger budget than mighty
number nine but uh yeah we'll have to
wait and find out another game that sort
of exists in that weird world but we
have seen gameplay for is scale bound
and microsoft sort of banged that dorm
real hard when it first came out
i feel like was it gamescom last year is
when they showed a big chunk of it i
think yeah i think i was at that
presentation um idiot guys excited about
that i feel like that's more in your
wheelhouse yes certainly than mine are
you excited about it i'm excited about
it because it's a cameo joint and i got
to like go to the studio last september
and like talk to them about scalebound
and whatnot and their vision for it
sounds really cool like it sounds like
it's like
it sounds like the game is being made by
a group of people that are like these
are our childhood dreams and like this
is what we thought would be cool and
like they're making it into a game and
that's cool to me because like we're all
kids at heart when we play video games
um also it's an rpg i'm gonna play it
because it's an rpg and it came from
japan so i feel like i have to play it
um but there's some things that i'm just
sort of like
well like the the the main character
seems a little
right he's like dante he's like yeah
he's kind of yeah he's like cool but in
a really not likeable way yeah he's like
the opposite side of because i was
really surprised my son said overdrive
hey they managed to actually hit that
one kind of right yeah like he's kind of
a dork and he's got a bit like cool for
school but but they ran with it they
were like we commit to the door
this guy is just like derpy-ish yeah
he's like a he's not i don't know he's a
little dirty i would not call him up to
hang out it's like an unpopular sigma
chi in a suit of armor right yeah
perfect
nice put on the box
freebie
like the dragon combat like like we've
seen we've seen we've seen footage of
flying on the dragon and the dragon
fighting and we haven't seen uh the
multi mulch of the multiplayer either
right have we seen dragon combat yeah
i mean like you fight in the dragon
fights and it does some stuff oh yeah i
wanna they they talk a lot about the
dragon and stuff the dragon can do in
like different colors for the dragon
yeah etc i don't know they've said
that's the hottest thing i want to see
more of like the game's sort of story
like we know it's a dude and his dragon
didn't they they made that was the movie
pete's dragon how to dude you're driving
his dragon how did you how to dude your
dragon basically that's what they should
call it how did you do your drugs you
should i mean you or the last guardian
they could just call it
dude your dog your dog
bird yeah thing dog bird let's not talk
about that man we're probably going to
see it at e3 the last guardian yeah
right i'm just right it's okay i wonder
if we're going to see a bunch of nomads
guy now because that's been delayed i
wonder if they're going to have to like
oh whoa whoa whoa all right all right
this is coming out in early august
you're going to have to show us a little
bit more i don't know i considering the
way the last week went with them yeah
maybe they won't maybe they just won't
yeah i don't know if they're coming it's
time for it so no but if like if like
power to them for saying we need more
time yeah yeah yeah i mean that's the
biggest game that studios ever made by a
mile they've like tripled in size i
think i mean they're still not a big
team but they've they've definitely
grown so yeah take your time okay let's
get into the weird world of rumors okay
rumors rumors rumors
uh jeep silver are going to announce
something new that's what we've with
that is being floated around at the
moment a lot of people are saying so we
look back at their old games you're
thinking their saints row which we sort
of beat that drama book goodbye there's
metro series they're dead rising uh or
sorry dead island um where where do we
think
that might
what would you like to see from them i'm
kind of done with saints row i love
saints row but i'm kind of like i think
it went on i think it ran its course i
think dad out of hell was like
all right yeah that might have been one
step too much almost like four might
have just been enough yeah and they
gotta have i was like yeah okay just
yeah party's over go home yeah um i'd be
excited for a new metro game what about
you oh man i was just gonna say metro
last light is one of my favorite games
um we talked about earlier when jimmy
was talking about the 1070 yeah running
that on the 10 air trying to run it at
full capacity on the 1080p so it can't
be done no
one card i think
metro last light maybe it's just my
instinct that to fill out a trilogy they
need a new game but if they did i would
not be because two two's if you haven't
played last night that ending is just
one of my favorite things in a shooter
ever but um i would be
super excited if they announced a new
one i think like those are something
like
there are traces of like half-life in
those games yeah and how they tell their
story and how you're playing that game
and the pacing i really hope that's what
it is let's talk about some of the big
guns rockstar games grand theft auto 5 i
mean they're going to be launching
gta online stuff for that for eons i
wonder if we're going to see any single
pair dlc i kind of feel like we won't
because it doesn't really make that much
money in comparison to what they're
doing with the duty online stuff uh but
can you see anything else from them i
mean the big one is like red dead
redemption right like everyone wants a
new red dead game yeah it might be that
i think it's too early for gta 6 um i
would like to see story dlc for gta 5 i
feel like the longevity of gta online in
the game itself i feel like i feel like
if they wanted to commit themselves to
single-player narrative dlc for that
game they could and they'd be fine
because
people liked it i mean gta 4 the battle
of gay tony was fantastic the yes
the biker one was called lost and damned
was really good too
uh yeah yeah well red dead as well
you've been like is it time like this is
their problem right is that they have
this suite of franchises the ones that
worked and the ones that didn't work
they got the warriors sitting over here
they got bullies kind of like somewhere
in the middle and then they've got the
sort of big guns do you think they have
to go for another red dead or do you
think you know maybe they'll they'll
show off something else and again this
being rockstar who generally tend not to
enhance big things at e3 either right
yeah that's sort of that's what sort of
makes me a little hesitant about it like
maybe it's not one of those big things
maybe it's something different
um i thought it might be agent but i'm
pretty sure agent is dead yeah
yeah i mean gta 5 they basically just
said yo we're going to put this trailer
up but this time everyone come and watch
it like they're big enough where they
can do that so i guess we'll have to
find out another big one of course being
um todd howard's team they have packed
fallout 4 is done and dusted the dlc for
that game i'm sure is being handled by a
smaller team whenever they seem to be
done they roll them out onto a new big
project and when they finished up skyrim
they all started work on fallout 4.
fallout 4 is now done are we going back
to the elder scrolls
yeah that's my wild card for the show is
right elder scrolls six the abyss or
whatever
it's kind of soon to announce in elder
scrolls obviously based on their the
pattern but yeah i don't know i wouldn't
be surprised if they did i'd be
surprised but pleasantly surprised and
the bethesda we have now is a different
bethesda than what we had like five
years ago where they could just rest on
one game every couple of years i mean
they have these press conferences now
and granted they've also like expanded
and they have its software and they've
been working with other teams around the
world you know when they had games like
wolfenstein and stuff that's underneath
their produce but that's being made by a
totally different team in europe it's
not even part of aid so like they do
have a lot of stuff going on but you
feel like bethesda if they are going to
do another one of these big events they
really need i mean they can't just have
like elder scrolls online stuff they
need they need stuff yeah like a big
game so yeah because it's just what
dishonored two right now
yeah and
maybe there's some doom stuff i don't
know as far as like new games right yeah
yeah um tango gameworks hasn't announced
what they're working on okay it could be
evil within successor or whatever right
yeah yeah but again that's on that sort
of bc tier right of like yeah so yeah
yeah hopefully that'll be amazing i mean
last year they stole the show so i bet
they'd probably like to do it all over
again uh let's talk about some of these
japanese games you got down here like i
love this i can always count on you for
this uh near automata new near game i
love near it was weird and stupid and
amazing and i'm so happy they're doing a
sequel that this game is actually being
made by platinum oh right platinum's
making near near automata there was a
not a press conference but walter was
while i was unconscious there was a um
like some new gameplay trailers went out
and it looked really cool and it looks
like a really good real-time action game
excellent so i'd like to see more of
that uh kingdom hearts three just hope
that's my wild card it's the thing i
hope to see um final fantasy 7 remake
i'd love to see something persona 5.
that game comes out in japan in
september of course so if it's coming
out this year then like i think atlas
would be kind of silly not to show it in
some capacity at e3 hopefully if it was
playable hopefully it's not too loud
because it's beside our booth on the
show floor we are beside her yes so i
had to listen to like that persona five
four dance the person before dancing
over and over and over again but you got
to see the teddy they did have a teddy
dancing in there so whenever i'm
interviewing people in the background it
was teddy just like doing his thing
amazing he was pretty good
those are my hopes my hopes and my
dreams not as far east but a little bit
well depending on where you are i guess
um is our good friends in warsaw city
project red uh cyberpunk 2077 obviously
something that they have been you know
there's a lot of you know fandom behind
all they've ever shown is that one
trailer which is pretty cool with that
bullet song great job all that hype uh
also though there was an earnings call
or like an investor thing they had back
in march where they talked about a brand
new game a new project which was
something that they said like isn't
going to be like any of the other
franchises they've worked on before so i
don't know what the hell that thing is
whether it's going to be a smaller thing
or a bigger thing and maybe they'll show
that thing off as well yeah whatever
that is
so
like a different genre or that sounded
like a yeah you can they did a
presentation uh marcin novinski did back
in and i talked to him i tried to talk
to him about it during gdc and he was
having none of it same yeah same here
right well i interviewed him about blood
and wine but he wasn't talking about
like cyberpunk they're so good they are
so good at being just like totally mom
totally i mean even with the witcher 3
like they were so they have the sort of
pr release things so good uh they've got
it
and they've delivered yeah which with
the witcher 3 so i think that's why
people are even more excited about
cyberpunk than they were before um but
yeah so we don't know what that thing is
we don't know what genre is i got the
impression it was a different genre i
got the impression it wasn't like a
spin-off of any of their other games it
was like a brand new thing i mean who
knows may they might make it bloody i
was about to say a collectible card game
but they already made gwen yeah
she can't be that oh no you said it's
not a spin-off because it'd be amazing
if they did like gwent mobile or like an
actual like gwent game would it though
how much i played it off gwen how much
money would they make though that looks
like instant money bloody baron that
goddamn green card uh that'd be great uh
they said you know we'll we'll we'll see
but you know cyberpunk not coming out
this year they've said as well so maybe
we won't we won't see it uh we'll have
to see anything else you guys are
thinking about i mean we haven't talked
about the hardware yes the playstation
4.5 neo stuff seems to be pretty set on
i mean there's been so many random
sources that have come out about it at
this stage right yeah
um i think i think that i mean and then
all the xbox one there's an xbox live
yeah
xbox slam there's the new one maybe next
year there's now all this chat about
virtual reality coming out of microsoft
which there wasn't
no separate to that it seems like yeah
yeah huh pete brown him being the expert
on a lot of these things he was saying
microsoft could kind of like steal the
show if they show off the stream box
like that a crackdown three would like
reportedly use but also like i think
they would need to be careful about not
using the word cloud because that every
time someone says i just kind of started
fading away but wait have they said that
now the crackdown 3 like physics
trailer yeah they said that was all
cloud stuff so that's why you could
destroy everything yeah but you said the
separate box nope so pete was saying
like there were there were rumors about
a stream box yeah right so like i don't
know oh just for like playing games oh
like it's streaming again i don't know
on live
i don't know i don't know if it's an
attachment or like so you could i don't
know i wish pete was here because he
could describe it way better than me you
can you can essentially like you could
use that cloud data to actually
like
negate the memory you need on your xbox
it like supplements it or something
right so like i don't know if they did
something like that that would be pretty
that might be the thing that sets them
apart from sony because i feel like sony
got out ahead of the game with their 4.5
stuff and that seems like like an
obvious increment but one of the
questions here from avengers for the win
uh
very salience says my question is why
would they release an xbox slim when
they're just going to release a new xbox
next year because that's what we're
hearing is that and who knows right this
might be the same rumor that's getting
split up somewhere along the line in
like a crazy game of telephone but
apparently they're saying that we're
going to have some sort of slim version
this year and then and then the new one
next year like if that's the case the
messaging around this is obviously two
weeks from now we'll know exactly what
it is yes i mean that does seem like
they'd be doing a disservice to the
you know school they're going to release
this year right it's all but it's also
the same as like the the whole
playstation 4.5 thing the 4.5 neo
whatever we're calling it is
is is
graphics like that's why it's being
released it's being released for
graphics and maybe improved memory and
nothing else like it's not going to have
the sony or rumors are saying that like
sony uh has i think austin walker's
awesome piece said that um sony has
already told developers that they cannot
make exclusives for either one
everything has to be the same like
one has to have they have to have a mode
for normal and regular for every game
that comes out and it's like
ah
like i don't know like i feel like it's
too ear i feel like it's too early still
yeah and then 2016. i didn't until
uncharted and doom came out and then i
was like oh no we're good like both
these games like doom runs at 60 and
looks amazing there's a bit of texture
pop on the on the console version as
there is actually on the pc version but
like
it's fine uncharted 4 looks amazing yeah
and you wouldn't want to play that game
in 60. like like that sounds crazy and
you know that would jump all over me for
it but like i love that game the way it
is exactly i think it's perfect it's
always i'm always curious how much that
the competition is pushing certain these
companies i mean i'm sure it happens all
the time but i'm wondering how much that
the catching one of the sony news caused
microsoft to say [ __ ] we should just
make the xbox smaller or something to
try to compete until next year yeah you
might be right i mean microsoft is
leagues and leagues and leagues behind
sony yeah uh at this point so they need
to do they need to come out
on par with them they need to be on par
and come out at the same time and be in
lockstep with sony or they're never ever
ever
going to catch up yeah i mean the
biggest problem they had forever was
that they were basically playing catch
up from the matrix era as well ever
since they've you know the new sort of
leads came in here so and then there's
an x
and then they're leading up and
explaining its whole thing who knows
maybe nintendo will pull the complete
like you know whoop on us and it's like
yeah here it is it's the nx it's a watch
it's a watch game game and watch we're
back it could be cause we give a watch
wasn't a watch but whatever could be
could be one now oh two weeks
two weeks
a little less than two weeks oh yeah by
this time we'll we'll know so much
already it's going to be beautiful
the electronic triple mike you excited
yeah that's my first game spot your
first one game spot yeah great
yay second e3 but first one of the games
sweet yeah you've already popped your
cherry and they're ready to go at it
again yeah yeah
like game spot all guns blazing yep
don't careful alexa i'm very excited
we're glad you're back i'm glad to be
back yeah wonderful to see you back uh
what are you doing over the next two
weeks because for
a lot of us this is kind of like hush
time like the dead zone like we've seen
a bunch of games come out we had doom
overwatch uh battleborn uncharted and
now we're kind of like that's it heart
bloodwine came out today nothing going
for two weeks what are you guys working
on for the next uh fortnight well i've
got uh star ocean i'm playing
and some other
jrpgs jrpgs that are also coming out at
the end of june if you're paying
attention you know what i'm talking
about um
and that's about it for now awesome what
about yourself mike i'm working on
wrapping up a few judges a week like e3
pre-e3 previews so we can have those
ready for e3 i'm traveling this weekend
cool to a city that i think if i set it
it might give away don't say it i won't
yeah i'm traveling warsaw yeah
yeah syracuse yeah oh yeah i'm hitting
up the hot development scene syracuse
new york
because casey powell lacrosse game was
made was that that was made in australia
but yeah casey was from australia yeah
it was the same studio that makes a lot
of those sports like aussie rules
something
same thing happened to the irish to the
gaelic football and hurling games was
made by an australian that's the same
studio i made casey paul across 2016.
they did not make very good
approximations of the irish sports i
would say that or
the most classic american sport no it's
all right huh is it okay the game yeah
no okay there you go
casey powell lacrosse
two 2016 2016 2017 seated e3 and
everything else thank you so much for oh
sorry sorry mike's not done talking
about lacrosse no i'm done are you sure
yeah no no do it do it i know what
you're gonna do what am i gonna do
you're gonna use some lacrosse assistant
let's just say if you're not going to
let me rip top cheddar in a lacrosse
game you don't know what you're doing
come on that's it thank you so much for
watching lobby here live sorry about our
five minutes of not knowing we were live
and talking like christopher walken at
the start of today's show uh thank you
so much to richard on camera good job my
friend and to all my overwatch buddies
in the back jean lucky uh mary kay eric
tay for producing this show as ever we
are done we got one last lobby before
e3 is on and we've also got a bunch of
our international folks coming in from
australia and london so make sure you
stay tuned come here back tuesday to be
pacific and we'll see you then for some
hot video games chat with a bunch of
people with even weirder accents than me
have a great week playing video games
see you next time
you